volver a casa después de 200 años Grecia
celebró Este viernes lo que el Vaticano
calificó como una donación ecuménica la
repatriación de tres piezas que
representan un caballo y dos cabezas
masculinas que pertenecían a la
Acrópolis pero se habían exhibido en los
museos vaticanos por más de 200 años
Esta es una pequeña parte de un inmenso
tesoro sería maravilloso si todo pudiera
unirse de alguna manera Esperemos que
así sea
la devolución de estas piezas es apenas
un pequeño logro en una lucha que ya
tiene más de 40 años Grecia pretende que
le sean entregados los frizos el templo
de erecteo arrancados a la Acrópolis a
comienzos del siglo 19 e incorporados a
la colección del museo británico en
Londres
es mi deseo personal y de todo corazón
que esta iniciativa marque un ejemplo
el Papa Francisco
mostró que esto es posible y
significativo
Los Defensores del museo británico
argumentan que la devolución del
fragmento de 75 metros socavaría las
colecciones de todos los museos del
mundo y atentaría contra la diversidad
cultural que estos muestran para el
gobierno griego estamos ante el saqueo
de un patrimonio histórico y Alaba de
Grecia no puede reconocer la posesión y
propiedad del museo británico porque
considera que el hecho de que las
esculturas del partenón estén allá es
producto de un robot el año pasado museo
de Palermo en Italia devolvió a Grecia
un trozo de una escultura de la diosa
Artemisa que formaba parte de su
colección gestos como este y el del
Vaticano añaden más presión sobre el
museo británico